thank you for coming to hear my talk so
I'm going to show you a portrait of all
the known planets in the universe 20
years ago and so back then there were
nine planets in our solar system since
then we've lost one unfortunately Pluto
but you know at that time extrasolar
planets finding planets orbiting other
stars other than our Sun was kind of a
fairy tale it seemed to be a fantasy
because planets are so much smaller and
so much dimmer than the stars that they
orbit it was it was a seemingly
impossible task to find planets like the
earth but in the 20 years since we've
made a lot of progress so here's
somewhat dated a three year old xk XKCD
comic showing all the known planets at
that time 786 of them and they're all
John's a scale and what I wish to draw
your attention to is that our planets in
our solar system are in this very small
gray box and that's not too surprising
given that bigger planets are easier to
find than smaller planets but certainly
in the initial years of finding planets
orbiting other stars most the planets
that we discovered were at least as
large or more massive than Jupiter
itself so it's only been in the last
several years that we've started
reaching down to smaller planets but
even 20 years ago astronomers and
astrophysicists were wondering what it
would take to reach out and discover our
nearest neighbors and so there was a
workshop held in may of nineteen
ninety-five called exploring nearby
planetary systems where a group got
together had a workshop and then
submitted a report to NASA and they
charted out a path towards eventually
obtaining a detailed image of an earth
analog way out in the future but in the
meantime they predicted that we would be
able to find an image accretion discs
where planets are forming and planetary
nurseries around very young stars and
that has happened that we would image
Jupiter's somewhere around 2006 and
essentially that kind of thing has
happened and that we would use
spectroscopy to start studying the
atmospheres of extrasolar planets and
indeed that has happened kind of
the timeline that's projected here one
thing this report did not do was it did
not recommend that we pursue transit
photometry as a method by which to find
planets in fact the prospects for
transit photometry were rather
pessimistic based on the report from
this workshop well here are all of the
exoplanet discoveries over time with
respect to the date the discovery year
that they were made and with respect to
the radius of the planet now this covers
all of the methodologies that have
resulted in almost all of the planets
including radial velocity which was how
the first planet was found 51 peg be
from the wobble method so you look at
the changes in the radial velocity or
the velocity of the star long line of
sight as it's dragged around in its
orbit about the Barrow center of its
system by its planets the ex nips group
also talked about estranha tree and we
have one planet discovered bias trauma
tree to date indeed back in 1989 a
curious object was found by Dave Latham
using radial velocity but it wasn't
clear at that point in time whether it
really was a planet and since then the
consensus is that it probably is a
planet but you can see that once we got
started in 1995 that people push down
the sensitivity to find smaller and
smaller planets over time and we've got
planets via imaging microlensing which
is a relativistic effect where you find
a planet through its perturbation of the
einstein ring as the star its orbiting
is creating a lens for a source star for
our distant and also through other
transit investigations so in fact the
first planet to be discovered to transit
across the face of its star was HD 209
458 be that was in the year 2000 and in
sometimes that's not a an accident for
the Kepler mission which it took a
number of years for us to convince our
colleagues that this was actually an
achievable mission our principal science
investigator bill berukhi submitted
proposals in 92 94 96 98 and in the year
2000 the same year that HD to a 945 80
was discovered showing that all these
planets
20 of them had been discovered it up to
that point we're really planets they
weren't some other kind of phenomena
Kepler was selected for launch and I'll
tell you a bit more about that but it's
very interesting to see how this is all
shaked out in the sense that transits
which were the under dog back in the
mid-90s and nobody wanted to do Kepler
it seemed other than the team that was
working on it has resulted in over a
thousand planets out of the roughly
1,900 planets that have been discovered
here 24 and back most of the planets
that we've discovered with Kepler are
smaller than neptune and most and more
of them are smaller than twice the size
of the earth than any others so it's
it's turned out rather interestingly now
over 500 of these planets have been
discovered by radial velocity and as you
saw in the last graph people have worked
really hard to push down the
sensitivities of radial velocity
instrumentation especially to reach down
to smaller and smaller planets and with
respect to the imaging that's just
something that's getting started and
it's very exciting so we're starting to
fill in parameter space in terms of long
orbital periods short orbital periods
and medium-sized orbital periods not to
mention the fact that aside from these
nineteen hundred planets there are over
4,600 planet candidates that have been
identified by Kepler and eighty to
ninety percent of those we believe are
real planets but it takes a lot of time
and follow-up work to confirm or
validate planet candidates I want to
talk to you now about what enabled
Kepler to be selected and it really was
a confluence of different things that
had to happen we had to demonstrate that
we could reach a photometric precision
with the instrument of about 20 parts
per million including all the noise
sources including stellar variability
that required the advent of back
backside illuminated ccds someone to the
chips you finding your in your cell
phones during your digital cameras and
we demonstrated in the lab that we could
achieve about 10 parts per million from
the instrument itself we required
sophisticated algorithms in order to
solve the challenges posed by the image
processing and the signal processing
that face Kepler to find these very weak
signal
against the background noise so here's
the focal plane you can see that's kind
of the crown jewel of the Kepler
instrument here's a float diagram for
the search algorithm that we employ to
do a joint noise characterization signal
detection algorithm and then we required
a computational infrastructure that was
capable of processing all this data in a
timely fashion so that we can take
advantage of advances in our knowledge
about the instrument in about the sky
well how does Kepler work in this
cartoon essentially we have a planet
that's crossing the face of the star and
I apologize that the media didn't
transfer over but you would see the
silhouette of a planet crossing the face
of the star and all the stars that
Kepler observes are typically one
thousand to three thousand light-years
away so we can't see the disk of the
star we can't see the silhouette of a
planet crossing the disk what we can do
is we can measure the brightness of the
star as a function of time looking for
instances when the planet crosses the
face of the star blocks a small amount
of light that will last for typically
several hours on this next slide will
show you how hard it is to find good
planets which we want to find the solid
planets that you or I could stand on
those are the ones of most interest
here's an image of the Sun with a
silhouette of a jupiter-sized planet
obscure Ian Jupiter is about ten times
smaller than the Sun and therefore when
it transits it cause is a one percent
drop in the brightness as seen over here
this is some real Kepler data with
though coverable drop in brightness here
is a silhouette of an earth-sized planet
crossing a son sighs star and it's much
smaller it's about ten times smaller
still than Jupiter and so it causes a
percent of a percent drop in brightness
or roughly 100 parts per million that's
why we need a noise level of about 10 to
20 parts per million in order to
reliably detect these signatures and
this is the first planet smaller than
Earth discovered around another star and
it has a drop in brightness of about
roughly 100 parts per million so that's
one major reason we have to go to space
you simply cannot achieve that level
precision from the ground so in March of
2009 we
the Kepler spacecraft to begin NASA's
first search for earth-sized planets in
the habitable zone of Sun sighs stars
and a month later we collected this
first light image now this is a really
big field of view and imagine it's about
the size of the palm of your hand held
at arm's length now compared to Hubble
which has a field of view about the size
of grain of sand this is really big over
100 square degrees in fact the full moon
would fit into the gap between our CCD
modules so that gives you some idea of
how big this field of view is now
they're certainly going to be other
future spacecraft with even larger
fields of view but this was certainly
novel for NASA to fly a mission like
this well one of the biggest problems
we've had with the mission is keeping up
with the data it certainly was easy at
first we have about 64 gigabytes of data
at the pixel level coming down each
month but over time that builds up once
we've accumulated four years of data to
search each liker for all the planets
requires about 30 billion 30 billion
matches or statistical tests and in
order to keep up with all that data it
took quite a bit well since I helped
design and played a primary role in
designing the science pipeline I can't
help but talk about a little bit so we
have about a million lines of code that
we've developed with 26 different
modules five of which are dedicated to
processing the science data so yes we
have to calibrate the pixels this is
some image data here we get some light
curves out this is a planet in this
light curve we have to estimate the
brightness or measure the brightness in
each in each image and then there are
instrumental effects that have to be
identified and removed from each of the
light curves before it can be subjected
to a transit search which we do in this
module over here a transiting planet
search once we've identified translight
features we fit physical models to them
and we construct a suite of diagnostic
tests that can make or break confidence
in each of these translate features in
terms of its planetary nature
nevertheless there's a lot of a lot of
stuff that comes out of data validation
that needs to be reviewed and vetted we
have a threshold crossing event review
team which is people to review
all of those events and then to decide
which become planet candidates in which
don't that's such a huge task that we've
been investigating machine learning
approaches to leverage off the wisdom of
the people who've been doing it for the
last six years to try to automate this
part of the process now in the closeout
mission because we're not no longer
taking data with Kepler that the goal of
Kepler's to determine the frequency and
distribution of planets not just to find
individual planets to do that job we
need to understand the completeness and
reliability of our science of our planet
finding pipeline so we've built in the
capability to inject artificial transits
and background eclipsing binaries which
can be confused as planets into the data
at the pixel level so that we can make a
careful measurement of both of these
quantities and therefore develop robust
estimates for the frequency and
distribution of planets in the galaxy
while the search problem is very much
like searching for a needle in a
haystack during the primary mission what
would happen is that we would have bales
of hay falling on top of our heads every
month and like I said it was very easy
at first to keep up with the data but
after a while it got harder and harder
and so about Oh two years or so into the
mission we've learned enough about the
spacecraft and about the sky that we
wanted to reprocess all the data and it
took us ten months and so by the time we
got towards the end of the primary
mission we realized it would take us two
years to reprocess all the data so we
began the task of porting all of our
code to run on the supercomputer and so
at first we just made all the code
parallel so that instead of processing
13 months segments of data at a time we
could process all of them all at once
and we found instances where the code
was slower than it needed to be when
you're a cost cap mission getting the
job done to schedule is more important
than getting the job done and having it
be running really fast so this is a
picture of the architecture that we had
that was local in terms of the clusters
that we used we had 700 cpus and about 4
terabytes of ram and about 200 terabytes
of raw disk storage we've sent built
this since built this up and doubled it
but in the meantime we've converted
everything to run on the supercomputer
so in fact here's the hyper wall with
our search algorithm four planets
running on it displaying the results and
it has over 200,000 cores about 700
terabytes of memory and lots of storage
I want to switch topics just a little
bit and talk and talk about the machine
learning approaches that we're using and
developing for vetting the candidates
because it's a really big job and so the
idea is to try to train a machine to
make the distinction between planet or
not planet and certainly during the
mission as we were going through we were
collecting much more data we're getting
a lot more transit like signals coming
out of the data most of which were not
real planets and it felt a lot like
loosing the Chocolate Factory that more
and more and more of these planet like
features would come by would need to be
reviewed and vetted here's a data
validation summary so this is a one-page
summary coming out of the pipeline for
one planet fact this is a plan I had a
very interesting planet that I'll talk
to you a little bit about in just a
little bit but this one page summary
sits on top of about a hundred pages of
the detail detailed diagnostics and
plots and so when we run our pipeline if
you took and plotted print it out all of
these data validation reports the stack
would be about 140 stories high so I
don't think anybody's ever tried to
print out all of the data validation
reports I hope they never do but you can
imagine that there's no way that any
human or group of humans can completely
understand and groc all the information
contained in all of those reports so can
we use machine learning to our advantage
to try to make an effort at doing so the
distribution of the transit like
features this is orbital period here you
see that in both cases of a search
through the first three years of data
and search through the four years of
data that we accumulated eventually but
there's a huge peak near the orbital
period of the spacecraft which is very
close to one year one earth year and
there's no Astrophysical reason to
believe that nature made lots of planets
in one year period orbits so most of
these are trash that's really
unfortunate because the
most important planet for us to find is
one that's small rocky and in an orbit
that permits liquid water to pull on its
surface if we're talking about a g2 star
like the Sun you're talking about an
overall a period of about one year so we
have to sort through all that stuff so
one of the ways that we're doing that is
by using a random forest algorithm and
these random forest algorithms basically
you build random decision trees on a
random subset of the training data and a
random subset of the attributes that you
have to make the decision with for each
node these are pretty nice because they
allow you to establish or measure the
importance of each attribute so maybe
the humans aren't looking at all 200
Quantic quantities that come out of the
search and data validation effort maybe
there is one or two or three that
they're missing that there really should
be looking at so it's nice to be able to
attribute the importance to each
attribute more perhaps more importantly
you can take the the voting record of
all the trees in your forest and use
them to score and then quantify the
reliability of the classifications that
have been made so you build a lot of
these in our case we build something on
the order of a hundred thousand trees
and then you let them vote on the
classification for each object now this
show the results of looking at four
years of data the blue stars are the
training data for planet candidates and
if everything we're perfect all the blue
stars would be up in the upper right
because then all the trees would have
voted for planet candidate status for
all of these objects which are largely
strong planet candidates or confirmed
revalidated planets from the past all
the green objects are Astrophysical
false positives these are the things
that go bump in the night that we know
why they should go bump in the night
eclipsing binaries background eclipsing
binaries those sorts of things so these
are kept learning clocks but they just
happen not to be planets and if
everything were perfect they would be
down all clustered in the lower
right-hand side the red x's are that are
the duds the banana peels that you don't
want to slip on and indeed it's hard to
see here but there are an awful lot of
them and ideally they would all be
positioned in the lower left if
everything went right well how do we do
so this shows
the error made and we achieve a
composite error rate of about four
percent or so which is actually really
good and that's given the disagreements
where the humans make disagreements this
is pretty good so it's very promising to
use machine learning approaches for this
classification problem and i'm really
excited by the fact that then you can
overlay a bayesian classification scheme
on top of this and essentially establish
class posterior probabilities for each
particular class that you have and why
this is important why you want to
measure the degree to which something is
a planet is that we're interested in
calculating the occurrence rates of
planets for each planet we do discover
there are at least two hundred others
that we didn't even see and are
sensitive using a hundred percent so
they're probably a lot more than that
and so we need to know our sensitivity
or completeness and reliability very
well but in the end when you're talking
about earth-sized planets in the
habitable zone of sun-like stars we
aren't going to have a large sample of
those and so we're going to have to be
at the hairy edges of the data that
means that we have to have a reliability
maybe this object should only be counted
as fifty percent of a planet rather than
a hundred sent we also want to make
ourselves robust against decision errors
right you don't want to have a ragged
edge that drags your statistics all over
the place because somebody decides that
this object is n or this object is out
you want to make it robust well one of
the only samples we have of a small
possibly rocky planet in the habitable
zone of sun-like stars kepler-452b and
we announced this back in july so just a
couple of months ago this is in a train
of discoveries so here's the earth and
the Sun up in the upper right in
December of 2011 with two and a half
years of data under our belts we
discovered Kepler 20 and I showed you
the light curve for that object earlier
it's somewhat smaller than the earth but
it's in a very short orbital period six
days so it's scorching hot it can't hope
to have an atmosphere let alone a liquid
water ocean on its surface so we kept on
searching and in fact in that self-same
month we announced the discovery of
kepler 22b this is the first planet
in the habitable zone of a g-type star
but it's over twice the size of the
earth and therefore unlikely to have a
solid surface upon which you or I could
walk so it may indeed be a water world
but we kept on collecting data and
indeed just over a year ago we announced
the discovery of kepler 186f which is
the first near earth-sized planet in the
habitable zone of a small cool M dwarf
star a red dwarf that's about half the
size and half the mass of our own Sun
that's indeed very exciting but a couple
of months ago in July we announced the
discovery of kepler-452b which is the
first small possibly rocky planet in the
habitable zone of a g2 star like our own
Sun to put this discovering into context
I'm showing the 186th system alongside
of Kepler 52 in our own solar system and
you let the green shaded region
indicates the habitable zone that range
of distances from a star for which
liquid water could pull on the surface
of a rocky planet and all of the planets
in the kepler-186 system including the
outermost 186f is this habitable world
is they lie within the orbit of mercury
in our own system so it's very important
what kind of star that you are but in
terms of how far you are kepler-186 this
is a compact solar system that's very
interesting but the habitable zone the
size and extent of that for 452 is
nearly the same as that of our own Sun
and indeed the orbital size for 450 to
be is nearly the same size as the orbit
of our own earth so this is the closest
we've gotten to finding a Sun earth
analog because the stars are so similar
452 and our own Sun we can look at the
evolution history of the habitability of
this planet in terms of the energy it
receives from its star over time
measured in billions of years the
current age that we estimate for 450 2 &
4 450 to be the planet is about 6
billion years earth is about four and a
half billion years old so both stars
become brighter as they grow
and evolve over time and so at this
point in time for 52 B is receiving ten
percent more radiation than we are today
from the Sun but one and a half billion
years ago we were receiving the same
amount of radiation so in fact this
planet because it's a little bit farther
from its star receive no more radiation
than the earth does today over the first
five billion years of its history and
that's a lot of time an opportunity for
life to arise if all the necessary
ingredients and conditions do exist for
that on this planet both earth and 450
to be will continue to evolve out of the
habitable zone over time as the stars
grow and evolve and get brighter but
we've got a lot of time to decide where
we're going to go and how we're going to
get there fortunately i won't i won't go
to 450 to be it's 1,400 light-years away
surely there are other planets much
closer a rate so this is a plot of all
the small habitable zone planets that
have been found by Kepler over the last
six years they're all under twice the
size of Earth the size of the disk is
scaled relative to the image of Earth up
here and there orient oriented with
respect to the surface temperature of
the star that they orbit and the energy
received is in earth units and again the
green shaded regions indicate either
conservative habitable zone or that
optimistic habitable zone respectively
but the thing to know here is that until
452 became on the scene all of the other
11 planets that have been discovered
like this have been discovered orbiting
stars that are significantly cooler and
smaller than our own Sun or somewhat
cooler and somewhat smaller than our own
Sun so we have about four that we've
detected around M stars these small cool
red dwarfs and about seven that had been
detected around k doors which are
somewhat cooler but can be significantly
smaller than the Sun so so far this is
the only example we have of a small
possibly rocky planet orbiting a g-type
star in fact a g2 type star very similar
to our own Sun so with that I'd like to
close my talk we know of two thousand
roughly planets orbiting other stars
it's quite amazing to see all this
happen in the space of just
years is just really amazing see all the
technology being achieved and then to
look forward to the characterization the
atmospheres of these planets in the
search for biosignatures nanospheres so
now that we know that there are a lot of
habitable worlds the job is to go and
find the inhabited worlds and that's
that's in the future but it has involved
a lot of serious data challenges and
it's really stretched all of our talents
with respect to the image processing
signal processing and managing all this
data and I look forward very much to all
of these other missions to come thank
you very much